[Music]
[Music]
walk into any Waffle House and you'll be
greeted by the familiar sounds of
breakfast bacon sizzling coffee brewing
hashbrowns crunchy and the piercing ding
of a waffle iron
ready for more batter but listen closely
and you'll hear a truly unique sound
[Music]
what's that there are raisins at my
toast who writes a song about toast
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen meet Shelby
I'm Shelby white and I'm the president
of waffle Records waffle what waffle
records is the in-house record label of
waffle house waffle records of course
waffle records was created as a way to
add waffle content to the jukebox we
originally created the songs in 1984
chairman say you know what we need a
record label
[Music]
there are currently 47 waffle house
songs on the jukebox some are songs on
the jukebox are especially at the waffle
house grill operator
I saw Elvis at the Waffle House building
a record label all about breakfast foods
is no small feat so Shelby and the team
at Waffle House turn to music producers
like Jason Phelps hi I'm Jason Phelps I
write and produce music for waffle
records to make us on for a while for
house it starts with an idea and that
idea generally is the title or what the
song is gonna be about sometimes the
idea is more serious like veterans
returning home but sometimes it's more
silly like having raisins in your toast
this last song that we did called only
at the Waffle House was very much about
crazy things that can happen to Waffle
House
Wow
[Music]
people give birth at the Wawa somebody
one time wrote a horse to the Waffle
House there are lots of things that
happen so the songs almost end up sort
of writing themselves once you have all
this good content we do take it very
seriously in terms of our craft but
music is fun and the waffle house is fun
who doesn't like that marriage
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well I'm our Stevie more I'm generally
known as one of the main pioneers of low
fidelity one-man band home recording
I've been recording for 50 something
years and I've made 400 albums a my home
[Music]
and now more TV more RCV more prolific
mr. Stevie more Stevie more yes I am our
Stevie more that when I was a younger
child I started my own idea of home
recording by myself my father was a bass
player doing all the country sessions
with all the stars of Nashville I had
access to tape recorders in my teenage
basement and I was a huge rock and roll
fan and absorbed all of these influences
I started messing around with writing
songs and making my own music do you
record the privacy of your own home is
that correct that's right now how do you
do that well late 60s is when I started
making my little albums I / dub all the
instruments myself I play bass and
guitars and keyboards and percussion and
vocals I got really good at it I've just
seven eight-nine tan overdubs and you'd
still hear the very first thing that I
used
did you invent home recorder of course
not but I took it to another level long
before it was customary I've probably
written about four or five thousand
songs they came out effortlessly I would
compile the most recent songs I wouldn't
pick and choose the best ones and throw
the worst ones on the floor and that's
been my aesthetic all along it's like
everything is released warts and all
because bad music is brilliant it's a
diary of sounds everybody that has ever
been a record collector loved to turn
their pals on the obscure why do you
hear this one I mean I do have that
reputation talking heads and b-52's and
we're all fans of mine naturally a lot
of these big artists have found my music
just word of mouth
but they never saw me because I was the
home hermit
she's doing more of it I filled up the
quantity without thinking about starting
over at the beginning to improve the
quality I've hardly ever performed and I
wasn't a bedroom guy it was always debt
home but the headphones on and then I
would work for hours and hours in 2010
things started to explode out of nowhere
suddenly I was in a band and touring the
world
I was playing hard rock shows big
festivals and tiny dives is incredible
my career really started taking off a
little too late in life often people say
I can't see how you've done this same
thing all this time without falling
through the trap and by avoiding the
mainstream nobody is gonna dare tell me
what I can and can't do feel so good to
have that integrity intact I'm proud of
all that I know I'm also still a little
kid
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Mikasa is como el museo abierto al mundo
latinoamericano yo creo que para una ask
me PETA's music Alison
nah collision blathers permit course
today le PES attend Ramos who knows in
the middle in depends discuss the
current technical revolution is closet
entire sort of Allah Fiona's war in time
in today's a minute our sport la musica
a lower risk in amateur sport casa nada
is una Drogo Panama min embrace
Alejandra fear lolita mass conocida como
Gladys Parma de SOI collector nested a
musical latina date all of you
you simply attend either Latin America
mu ether compadre raha ye madre force de
Panama either Chiquitita impetus couch
este tipo de musica no panel Taniya
Quattro Cinque wanna go entertain a
collection are one dose to viviendo nano
and Panama Conde ph1 use when I aquí en
la collective anymore
musica practica mental auspices the
Latin America vamos realmente a complete
our lo mejor de la mejor de la musica la
vie okay creo que Tomatina the richer
sólo unos cuantos yo creo que quiero and
are muchísimo mass in la revista musica
para comprar ner la cantidad de grupos
Kebede on the cha cha cha hua lu l mambo
pass proof of this and De Profundis and
Eau de Verano pilot and everything you
know I waste Oh para mi So La Ti todas
topology on me there s compartir con
todo mundo yeah fun Macedo poder el dia
de mañana para esta elección honesty to
fuel pull their blow on El Al a
disposition public o volka persona wait
a minute Kyoko litchi on a poder pushed
in her face at all wisdom travel is
kakizaki theorem Astoria in tanana
particularly de that in America is una
Monica de musica is Castillo Correa
discover the school bro in mr. Brentano
request oversee comment a poor pasion
Amin muchísimo brother poder de ver esto
es el mundo era is for Mira
[Music]
many people know the sound of vinyl but
it's how it's made that's a whole
different story the record industry
offers a one-stop shop for all our
customers so we do the cuts in house on
both lacquer DMM
we produce our own compass we do the
print of all the sleeves
labels so the customer doesn't have to
go to other printers or cutting rooms to
to get all the stuff together we do
everything in-house
[Music]
this is tong the proud owner of record
industry one of the largest final
pressing plants in the world located in
Harlem in the Netherlands Tom has had a
lifelong love of vinyl I started this my
music career as being a DJ in a local
club pirate radio stations playing the
old disco dance grooves in the 80s the
factory opened in 1958 in recent years
has seen a surge in sales last year we
did nine and a half million and this
year we're aiming for 10 million 500
maybe 11 million we press for all the
major companies being Sony Music
Universal Warner Music and a lot of
local smaller labels my wife and me try
to run record industry as being a
feminine company we don't have children
ourselves but at the end we're always
making a bit fun of it and we say we
have a hundred children here I like the
vinyl I like the size of the format nice
pictures you know you can say you can be
proud on this product and if you look at
a CD for instance it's not something
you're cherishing a record to cherish
the music was more some kind of a hobby
so I could turn my hobby into a real
professional in this beautiful plant
[Music]